clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic abbott toi et puis c'est le retour
des vidéos dans lesquelles on
s'intéresse aux petits trucs insolite
élan il se forma a désormais un nom
puisqu'il s'appelle sans son bord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la dernière fois on avait parlé d'eux
tandis de la chaîne can dance et de sa
soeur
ils sont la weed aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser au talent de juliette de la
chaîne parlons peu mais parlons qui a la
particularité d'éternuer environ 1000 m
parce que le monde se divise en deux
parties ce qui est perdu une seule une
grosse fois pour toute et ceux qui
éternue systématiquement deux fois trois
fois quatre fois où une fois de suite et
on avoir une autre alors déjà pourquoi
on était amis vignerons c'est rigolo
mais à quoi ça sert je sais pas si vous
vous en rappelez on en avait déjà parlé
dans la vidéo sur l'écran tenait le nez
et une sorte de filtre sert à réchauffer
l'air à l'humidifier et à emprisonner
des petites particules qui nous
empêchent de rentrer pour éviter qu'elle
a juste à notre mieux pour les capturer
il est équipé de deux systèmes ultra
perfectionné des poils et du mucus de la
manche guerman même s'ils en restent pas
tout à fait ça pour se débarrasser de
ces petites cochonneries coincé dans les
poêles et dans le mucus ya plusieurs
écoles soit housse mouche et plus soit
on attend que ça sèche ça devient des
crottes de nez et là chacun a fait des
coupes personnel pas soit on laisse
couler dans l'ariège blanche et mais
parfois ces petits peu chémery celles
des grosses conneries ou alors y en a
trop et dans ces cas là on a des
capteurs dans milk déclenché une alarme
et en même temps un réflexe qui consiste
à expirer brutalement du l'air on était
ça marche aussi par exemple quand on se
chatouillent le front du maire et d'un
cheveu ça c'est un petit truc que je
donne pour déclencher un éternuement
qu'ils veulent c'est cher et pareil si
on respire un truc dans le genre du
froid des vapeurs toxiques ou une
chronique d'eric zemmour et y en a même
qui a été remis à cause du soleil et ça
on va parler bientôt dans ce milieu
ouais alors un truc pas combien on été
revu par la bouche et parlement
vous avez vu dans les deux cas c'est
dégueulasse ça envoie la mort et des
germes partout dans l'air donc est sympa
comme des perdus
mettez la main devant la bouche et
devant le nez et à les laver les mains
et il faut savoir qu un éternuement
c'est un truc balèze à long terme de
puissance et de vitesse de l'air qui
expulse et on entend dire grappes de
tout et n'importe quoi les plus vieilles
si tu te laisse penser on était proche
et 350 kilomètres en plus
raisonnablement dans la doute qu'ils
avancent plus de 150 km h et plus
récemment des études mais avec les voix
ne peut pas le voir avance le chiffre de
15 km h qui pourra monter jusqu'à 50 60
kilomètres donc lier ces balles est bon
en réalité parce qu'on tire donc s'en
fout un peu
déjà parce que c'est pas une course
comme éternuements arrêtez un peu avec
la compagnie à tout prix et qui ensuite
parce que ça varie pas mal d'une
personne à l'autre et ça on va retenir
un éternuement c'est une expiration a
cédé n'est suffisamment des nerfs pour
risquer potentiellement d'abîmer la
gorge les parois des mondes l'étape en
foire les vaisseaux du cerveau si vous
éternuez en vous couchant mai et en
avant la mue donc elle passa en faut que
ça sorte
alors pourquoi on éternue pas tous de la
même façon
ça dépend de plein de trucs comme de la
forme et de la structure de ne tenaient
des autres nos visages et de nos voies
respiratoires mais aussi de notre
personnalité si on en croit un
neurologue et psychiatre nommé alan
hirsch qui compare sa peau vire on n'a
pas le même rire ni les mêmes des
arguments suivants mais ni où
travaillent les apéros mais il ya aussi
une explication qui est beaucoup plus
pragmatique on éternue
tant que le boulot n'est pas fini si la
forme d'un visage ou votre timidité ou
fait égard nu et tout doucement par
exemple il vous faudra peut-être trois
fois pour arriver
genre une fois pour décrocher le truc
chat le fond nude et une deuxième fois
pour amener vers l'avant et une
troisième fois l'exclusivité est donc
c'est tous ces critères mis bout à bout
qui vont déterminer s'il peut être dans
la team j'éternue une fois ou deux
derniers deux fois
ou trois fois où environ dix fois sans
son corps c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout orthez
[Applaudissements]